there may be no other concept that
captures the imagination more than the
idea of time travel the ability to
travel to any point in the past or
future what would you travel through
time to see you could go back and meet
yourself at an earlier age or go forward
and see how you look in the future it is
these possibilities that have made time
travel the subject of so many dreams and
stories lots of us think we know what
time is but it is hard to define you
cannot literally see or touch time but
you can see its effects and everything
around us our bodies age buildings
crumble trees grow our lives are often
dictated by what time we need to be
somewhere time is also described as
being the fourth dimension to our
universe the other three dimensions are
of space including up-down left-right
and forwards and backwards time cannot
exist without space and likewise space
cannot exist without time the
relationship of space and time is called
the space-time continuum this means that
any event in the universe has to involve
both space and time
most people think that time travel is
impossible but believe it or not there
is no law of physics preventing time
travel it was thought that time was
fixed and never deviated but it's
actually more abstract time can in fact
be twisted turned and even looked into a
pretzel this allows for time travel
the speed of light is about 300,000
meters per second an Einstein theory
states that as an object near the speed
of light time slows down at the speed of
light time stop to understand this
imagine two twins one us into a new
spaceship traveling at almost the speed
of light while the other stays on earth
if the boy on earth could check his
sister's watch he would find that it was
taking much slower than his own when the
girl returned from space her brother
would have felt 80 years go by while she
has only felt 40 years go by because
time was moving a lot slower for her the
twins would look at each other one old
and one young the twin who went to space
has essentially traveled 40 years ahead
in time the only problem with this is
that you must be traveling near the
speed of light to make any effect and
the fastest human spaceship travels at
only a tiny fraction of the speed to get
near the speed of light we would need to
harness the energy of a star another
theory of time travel was proposed by
physicist
Ranma lat he claims to have figured out
how to make a machine that uses a
circulating beam of light to twist space
and because space and time are connected
his machine to us time this is a model
of his machine real machine will be
about the width of a human hair and with
about 10,000 lasers the lasers work
together to twist the space-time
although this machine won't be able to
think humans back in time they're
planning to use it to thin tiny
particles or information back in time
imagine being able to use it in the
future to send back the cure for AIDS or
cancer the idea of time travel creates
many paradoxes one famous one is the
grandfather's paradox but if you were to
go back in time and kill your
grandfather how could you have ever been
born to go back in time and kill them
many mathematicians believe that the
answer to this is that there are an
infinite number of parallel universes
and every time you make a decision you
create a new universe that was the same
up until the point you made that
decision so if you were to go back in
time and kill your grandfather you would
just create another universe without you
in its future may
in outer space aliens have perfected
time travel or maybe our descendants
have harnessed the energy of a star so
someone knocks on the door claiming to
be your great-great-great great-great
grandchild don't slam the door because
maybe you're descended a thousand years
into the future
got into a time machine to visit their
ancestor